[Music]
I'm thank you for joining us I'm John
Langan we do start with that breaking
news a 16 year old died at Desert Oasis
High School this happened yesterday
Clark County School District says the
students suffered a medical issue while
playing sports Joshua peguero is live
near campus this afternoon with the
story Josh what's the latest
the Clark County coroner's office
identified the victim as a Shari huge
students and families were notified of
her passing this morning by the Desert
Oasis High School principal Ian Salzman
at this time the cause and manner of
death is still pending to be released
staff began performing immediately
Medical Aid yesterday and continued
until paramedics arrived according to
the principle Hughes was described as a
student athlete principal Salzman says
parents need to monitor their kids for
signs of grief or behavioral changes the
CCSD crisis response team will be
available for any students or staff who
need their services superintendent Dr
Jesus Jara also sent his condolences
saying the district is saddened by the
sudden loss and their thoughts are with
the family friends and loved ones of
Miss Hughes reporting live near Desert
Oasis High School Joshua peguero eight
news now Josh thank you very much you'll
certainly follow the story all through
the day ccsd's crisis response team is
available for student students and staff
at Desert Oasis or anywhere else make
sure to remind your children there is
someone to talk to about their grief